[Music] [Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yesterday
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
but i had to pretend to be someone i
wasn't the whole time so it didn't even
feel like i got laid it felt like my
character got laid
i'm in bed like i had a partner
a lot of ladies call me a premature
ejaculator which hurts my feelings
premature to do
[Music]
it's kind of difficult for me to [ __ ]
because uh 99 percent of my sex career
was so low
and now i have to have an orgasm while
someone's breathing on me
[Music]
how am i supposed to come but i don't
have the
office chair on my
ass i'm in my office chair i'm gonna
come
quick give me a mouse
i think porn gives an unrealistic image
of women
it shows them saying yes and being nice
experiencing
[Music]
it's not pleasure women in my life
a lot of firm handshakes and nice
it's uh great to be watching porn
nowadays um yeah some girl is [ __ ]
dumb
why are you talking so much
because you're at a comedy show and
you're not supposed to do that
did you uh
want to get kicked out
um but yeah thanks for participating
maybe next time you can spend 10 years
doing open mics and get up on the stage
yourself instead of ruining other
people's
[Applause]
you're making
it's kind of weird to be watching porn
though because that online is also where
i date
so one
dearest amanda
what color is your hair
but um i love
online dating because it's not really
like a dating app it's more like a
smartphone game where if you win you get
to touch a girl
um it's kind of weird because nowadays
you have to have a bumble you have to
have a tinder okay cupid you know it's
like you have to start a small pr form
just to get
here's my press packet
someone touched my dick already
but uh i love talking to girls uh face
to face in the real world um i was
telling this girl she was like did you
know that my vagina can make a baby so
my vagina is a 3d printer
i was like actually your womb is a 3d
printer your vagina is the tray
[Music]
it only prints one thing with lots of
errors
takes nine months to print
and the whole time is printing is
complaining
needless to say i did not see any trays
that night
i love
women i think they're really good at
giving birth
they dominate the competition
[Music]
is like 27 pounds
[Music]
i used to date this woman who was really
into yoga and choke sex
i was like do you enjoy breathing or not
millennial
i love how millennials are such
narcissists nowadays that if they're not
a seven or above they'll just dye their
hair pink and chase your gender
[Music]
it's like why just be a four and learn
how to play
[Applause]
[Music]
i am very gender fluid i am biologically
male but my bullies identified me as a
[ __ ]
i think trans people should be able to
use whatever bathroom they want to use i
just don't think suicidal people should
because they don't always clean up after
themselves
a bit messy
is
my pronouns are he him please respect
them
i love telling people my pronouns
because then they have to pay extra
attention to me and i didn't have to do
any extra work to get it
i saw a bicyclist recently who
identified as an automobile so i think
that person is trans
jersey was kia
over here in texas i love rednecks
because rednecks can survive in any
wilderness situation that you put them
in
except a situation where everyone has
equal rights
you can live in a swamp with an
alligator why can't you live
my friend told me recently that the
government is run by pedophiles i like
to drink the blood of children
but luckily he's not getting vaccinated
or masked
i should take care of that problem
i love to help but i got vaccinated
i do love wearing my mask because i'm a
liberal and i love to smell my own fear
it turns me on sexually
[Music]
i was at a walmart and i saw a guy take
off his mask to sneeze
how does this guy [ __ ]
i love the uh marvel
cinematic universe my favorite marvel
movie is the black panther movie because
the black children a hero they could
look up to
and not just someone like martha king jr
or malcolm x or harriet tubman marshall
or george rushman carver maya angelou
rosa products
[Music]
[Applause]
now there's a fake person that dressed
like a cat
when are they going to come out with a
yellow panda
[Music]
[Laughter]
asian men [ __ ]
you're a very crucial part of the sexy
process
please stop trying to skip us
if you have sex with us our children
will be very beautiful
half of them
the other half will be great engineers
[Applause]
i don't like how asian women act like
they're hotter than asian men because we
look exactly the same [ __ ]
[Applause]
why are you impregnating fun white dudes
[Applause]
the most perverted people ever
i could throw on a wig and be a seven
relax
i know asian women you're hot here in
america but just remember back home
we're throwing you away
we're trying
stay humble ladies
you're an away team
i love being asian because i can walk
into starbucks and tell them that my
name is ching chong bing bong
[Music]
and they have to write it down
what are they gonna say
hey that's all your name
excuse me skyler
i come from a long line of big moms
like people are so
so racist it just hurts my feelings
this guy was like uh
whichever way
is like dude just because i look like
this doesn't mean i speak your move
language
the post office is right there
i'm obviously not a racist i'm a
minority how could it be impossible
i don't even see race i mean i barely
see much of anything
[Music]
especially in those ubers am i
[Music]
i right actually on an airplane and i
saw a dude reading a book in arabic
which kind of freaked me out
but then i saw him fold the corner of
the page and put the book away and i was
like oh thank god
[Applause]
he used to be a regular at the comedy
store in that way very funny guy opens
up for amy schultz all the time for
derek
[Applause]
[Music]